you walk alone into a room and you find
a chess board each of the 64 squares has
a coin sitting on top of it this is
going to be one of those classic
prisoner puzzles where a strangely math
obsessed Warden offers you and a fellow
inmate a chance for freedom but only if
the two of you solve some elaborate
scheme that they've laid out in this
case what they've done is carefully
turned over each of the coins to be
heads or tails according to whatever
pattern they want it to be and then they
show you a key they put that key inside
one of the chessboard squares
each square is a secret compartment or
something like that so you know where
the key is and the goal is going to be
to get prisoner number two to also know
where the key is but the only thing that
the warden allows you to do before you
leave the room is to turn over one and
only one of these coins at that point
you walk out your fellow prisoner walks
in and with no information other than
the set of heads and tails that they're
looking at which you've only barely
tweaked they're supposed to deduce where
the key is hidden potentially winning
freedom for the both of you